so those so these are separate Gods then
yeah
[Music]
it is here at Cal State Fullerton and we
just met my two new friends and what's
your name again other plums Elder plants
and then we have Elder hurts the other
hers so uh we got two young Elders from
the latter day uh Saints right the
Church of the Latter-Day Saints tell us
a little bit about the basic
um you know I guess what you guys how
you introduce yourselves when people
come because a lot of people I would
assume have you know misconceptions
about Mormonism yeah no absolutely so I
guess it would be interesting to
ourselves as we're missionaries for the
church we just share uplifting messages
about Jesus Christ to help people and
it's kind of like give people a lot of
their perspectives on things too right
just just like chat it up yeah yeah
that's good I love talking about Jesus
about God that's awesome a lot of people
don't especially in the culture right
now you know in Israel they just like
basically shut down talking about Christ
which sucks I don't know if you guys
heard of them but they're like literally
Banning Christianity in Israel so it's
it's dope that you guys are doing like
are open to this and brave enough to do
that
um so obviously let's get right down to
the nitty-gritty because I don't have
you guys long enough so huge uh miscon
or things that are said maybe some
misconceptions
um things that I've heard myself is that
Mormonism mormonives teaches like a sort
of polytheism is that true like that the
father is a God and Jesus Christ is a
God and uh like the holy spirit is
another God Like These are three
different gods maybe we can all become
Gods one day is that a real teaching in
Mormonism or is that like just hearsay
so that's kind of like hearsay so we do
believe in like God the Eternal Father
his son Jesus Christ and the Holy Ghost
are three separate percentages and that
they are Gods so it's like like Jesus
Christ is a God God is like with God
though
[Music]
so these are separate Gods then yeah
okay I guess you could say that but like
I guess when people hear that they think
like oh like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so is it is it any different
from that yeah it's just like three Gods
okay so wow well in Greek mythology they
have more than just the three gods and
Mormonism it is three different gods so
when it comes to that then
um
when it comes to like okay so somebody
was bringing scripture into this and
they were asking you okay guys I hear
what you're saying but there's a lot of
verses that I see in the Bible that
talks saying that God is only that
there's only one God right and that he's
by himself he knows of no other God
right how would you guys I guess
reconcile these type of verses with like
the Mormonism beliefs so yeah one one
example that we bring up is the baptism
of Jesus Christ because when he's
baptized we see the Holy Ghost descend
in a form of a in the form of a dove and
we hear Heavenly Father speak and say
this is my beloved Son hear ye him
and and so like another thing too is
that heavenly father Jesus Christ and
the Holy Ghost are separate and distinct
but they form one godhead and they are
one and purpose and so especially in the
Bible we see a lot of the father is in
me and I am in the father what what we
believe that he's teaching is that he is
one in purpose while they are separate
and distinct they ultimately have the
same goal okay so you're saying that
they're one in the sense that they have
the same purpose but not the same like
nature per se like the father-son are
they have set their own separate Natures
their goddesses of the God the father is
his own being God the son is his own
being separate God but they're one unit
United in their purpose yeah or their
mission when Jesus says like oh like you
know you've seen if you've seen me
you've seen the father you know they're
they're all doing the same thing like
he's doing the exact same things God
would do so then so that that brings me
back to the question if God says in the
scriptures that there's no God besides
me right how do you guys reconcile that
type of belief with the scripture and
you look at it when he says God in that
way it's actually with a capital G and
and when it talks about Jesus Christ
it's like lowercase two like he's like
the God and it's like Jesus Christ
so you're saying that Jesus is called a
God in the scripture
whoa this is new to me is is there is
there a place where you guys can show me
this
I know that okay so what I'm familiar
with is is John 1 where he talks about
the word it says that the word is God
not a god though
um you have Titus
Titus Chapter 3 and Timothy that talks
that says Jesus is our great Lord and
Savior our great God and savior but I've
never seen words that cause him like a
god oh yeah this will be new to me I'm
open to it though oh yeah yeah and this
will know and John that that instance we
talk about we actually because one of
the words for Jesus is the word that's
right so it's like the meaning was the
word Jesus Christ and the Word was with
God
and the Word was God Jesus Christ yeah
same you know wanted purpose like he's
God so not a god though here right
because that's important
like what do you mean like because if
it's if it were to say that he is a God
then that would then mean that he is a
separate
deity he's a separate God than God the
father but if it just says that he is
with God and he is God then they're not
separate maybe distinct in persons
because they do communicate they do have
a relationship but they share the same
nature as the one God
but like two separate beings two
separate two distinct persons oh we're
like sharing the same position yeah so
you're in the same nature that's what
I'd say okay that's good then because
that's that I don't know yeah it's like
our terminology can be like it's it's
stuff like when you say we believe in
the you know the same like there they
are one that's what we really got to ask
or what exactly do we mean by one
because what you mean by one could be
different from what I mean by one you
know what I'm saying yeah absolutely so
it's really impre uh important that we
bog down on this all right last question
so that you guys can go
um so I've heard it said that Joseph
Smith you know he taught that God was
not always God our heavenly father was
not always God but that he became God
right at some point because of his
righteous deeds and things of this
nature became God and then also that we
can become Gods one day as well if we
continue on this path and you know stay
right to some of us is that hearsay or
is that is that fact so that is
something Joseph Smith said I haven't
done much study on it though I can't
really give you a really good answer but
kind of what I thought of is like you
think of like you have like your
father's business right and he wants you
to have everything he has right So
eventually he like teaches you you start
your own business it's not more
successful than your college but you
have your own business this is kind of
like
oh sure you're not better than like your
father but like let's say your business
is exactly the same you know it's kind
of I don't know that's the way I've kind
of thought about it so okay so with with
this being said if he's teaching that
there was a point in time where our
Heavenly Father God was not always God
that like guys I'm saying this in love
that is literally against the scripture
like the scripture literally says that
God has always been God from eternity
past like he's the same yesterday today
and forever right he's never changed so
if someone is coming and saying oh well
I will refute that God has not always
been God but he became God like that's
that's a blasphemy in the scriptures you
know it's like for someone like me who's
hearing this for the first time hearing
this outside like that this is something
that I wouldn't I can't reconcile if
because the scripture is our Authority
right would you so scriptures are
Authority it's how we can know if
someone is in line with God right so if
they're teaching something that's not
scripture then we can be like nah that's
he's he's he's he's going against the
word of God he's not a prophet that's
that's what I do with Muhammad right
right that's how I know Muhammad is not
true because he doesn't line up with
scripture what are you guys thoughts on
that and you guys can go ahead
so I think especially with
like
God before he became God I feel that's
more of an assumption that people make
based off of what we call the Plan of
Salvation
and the first point of the Plan of
Salvation is that before this life we
all lived with Heavenly Father in heaven
but we are only Spirit children but
Heavenly Father
had things that we wanted which were a
body of Flesh and Bones and experience
and so he created The Plan of Salvation
which includes us coming here on Earth
to obtain these things and so
I feel and this is just me personally
this isn't anything with the church okay
but I feel that especially with
with
like think questioning whether what was
before God I think that's more of like
assumptions off of what we believe
outside of true so that that's good then
so because okay we agree can we agree
that God in his nature he has to be
infinite always existing right he's the
creator of all things right so he's the
source of everything there's nothing
before him like he literally says I'm
the beginning I'm the end right there's
nothing before me nothing after me right
right so if someone comes and then says
well no no no there was actually
something before God
and that God has not always been this if
like if Joseph Smith taught this if
we're talking about scripture and we're
being real guys that would be a
legitimate false teaching according to
scripture right
right so if that is true and God you
guys can like if you guys disagree me
trust me it's okay I still love y'all
okay perfect perfect and so if
somebody's coming like this and this is
important like if I'm you know Gonna
Leave You guys leave you guys with this
focus on script like we have to focus on
scripture even if someone like Joseph
Smith came teaching something opposite
of scripture this is how we know that
someone is not right with God okay any
last words uh that you guys want to say
it's not important to like you know
reading scriptures like after you read
them and stuff it's like guess like in
James 1 5 like I need you lack wisdom he
has asked for it that's right right God
wants to give you answers that's right
that's right
here appreciate you guys coming yeah
thank you